هو البالون الذي اغضب واشنطن واحدث هزه
دبلوماسيه جديده في علاقتها مع بكين سبعه
ايام قضاها المنطاد محلقا فوق امريكا
الشماليه قبل ان يتعرض للاستهداف وفق
نيويورك تايمز في هذا اليوم دخل المنطاد
وانحرف نحو المجال الجوي لاسكا بالقرب من
جزر الوشيان بحلول نهايه هذا اليوم خرج
المنطاد من الاراضي الامريكيه ثم عاود
المنطاد دخول الولايات المتحده فوق ايداه
وشق المنطاد طريقه الى السماء فوق بلينجز
اكبر مدن ولايه مونتانا التي توجد بها
قاعده مالمستروم الجويه التي تضم 150
مستودعا للصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات فيما اوردت التقارير ان منطادا
صينيا ثانيا يسافر عبر امريكا الوسطى
متجها نحو امريكا الجنوبيه بكين ذكرت من
جانبها ان البالون هو بالون طقس انحرف عن
مساره متاثرا بالرياح الغربيه اما في هذا
اليوم فاسقطت مقاتله من طراز اف 22
المنطقه الصيني فوق المحيط الاطلسي قباله
الساحل الشرقي للولايات المتحده تلك هي
رحله المنطاد الذي تسبب في الغاء زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى بكين
كما اغتنمها الجمهوريون فرصه اخرى لمهاجمه
بايدن انتقادا لعدم اتخاذ اجراءات اكثر
صرامه ضد المنطاد وضد مطلقته الصين